Russian officials say one of their oil
tankers has been hit in a Ukrainian
drone attack in the Black Sea they said
the vessel's engine room was damaged in
the overnight strike but that no one was
hurt it reportedly happened south of the
bridge that links Russia to Crimea
officials in Ukraine have not yet
commented on Friday a Russian ship was
attacked by a Ukrainian Naval drone
strike near the Russia's Port of
novorowski Daniel Hawkins is joining us
now live from Moscow what's Moscow
saying about this latest incident Daniel
well as you said this is the second time
that Russian ships have been targeted in
24 hours the Ukrainian authorities
released a video which purports the show
this Naval drone approaching the Sig oil
tanker which was of course under a
Russian flag but traveling to Russia
from a different area Reports say this
was from Turkey there were 11 crew
members on board and following this
attack the ship sustained damage which
caused that the Tilt to one side and
take on quite a bit of water in one of
its compartments now Russian Rescue
Services say two tugboats were
dispatched to take the ship back to
shore there were no serious casualties
reported on board and the ship will be
repaired however photos on social media
show quite substantial amounts of water
on board this ship and quite a lot of
debris scattered around the rooms and
the control room as well now Ukrainian
authorities of course haven't officially
confirmed or denied involvement though
there was a tacit admission if you like
from the head of the sbu who said that
such quote Special Operations are
logical and are legal as they take place
in Ukrainian territorial Waters the
Kremlin of course takes a very different
view labeling these sorts of attacks as
terrorist incidents whether on Russian
military or civilian infrastructure in
that area and Daniel of course all of
this happening is the fighting is going
on in the front lines what's Russia
saying about that
will have been intensive attacks on the
southern zaporization front as part of
the Ukrainian counter-offensive which
has been ongoing now for some weeks
meanwhile as Ukrainian forces try to
push into Russian fortifications in the
South the Russian modu says the Russian
army has been conducting offensive
operations in the north on the borders
of the lugouts Republic today they've
said they've taken under control the
settlement of Nova solovskaya which is
on the borders of logansk and regions
they've also said the Russian armies
captured around 11 Ukrainian defensive
fortified positions in that area as well
we've seen quite pitched battles going
to and from the two cities of marimca
and of divka in the donbass as well
marinka particularly just like we saw in
bahamuta city that's been very badly
damaged by the fighting and it's pretty
much split between Ukrainian and Russian
control and the city of avdhivka which
the Russian forces have been trying to
encircle for quite some time as the
Ukrainian Army counter-attacks and tries
to stop that from happening now the
Russian mod have also said they've
intercepted around eight hymas Rockets
over the last 24 hours and 22 drones
some of which targeted Donetsk and as
well as the battles continue across the
donbass in both sides try to make
progress Daniel thank you very much
indeed Daniel Hawkins talking to us from
Moscow